more than five million people worldwide
are now believed to have died as a
result of the kovid 19 pandemic
and in the prosperous west many
countries are looking forward to the
coming winter with apprehension
though have been celebrating the lifting
of restrictions imposed on people's
personal freedoms meanwhile intensive
care units are again bracing for a surge
in patients
and in large parts of the global south
things are worse much worse with only
about five percent of people fully
vaccinated
so on to the point we ask five million
covet 19 deaths and no end in sight
[Music]
[Music]
well thanks very much for being us being
with us here on the show and i'm joined
in the studio by pippa stevens from dw's
science department who says the pandemic
will end but that end point will not
provide the comfort that many are hoping
for
also with us is jacob zimanc doctor and
science journalist with the weekly paper
deed site and jacob argues that quite
simply this winter vaccines alone will
not suffice
and on the line from bonn is hendrick
strike a prominent virologist at the
university of bonn
who believes the pandemic is far from
over and we are all part of it
vaccinated or not
well thank you all three for being with
us today and thank you for those
introductory statements we'll go
straight to bonn and uh professor strike
and this figure of five million lives
that have now been lost to covet 19. uh
un secretary general antonio guterres
said it's a painful new threshold is it
something that you as a seasoned
scientist can take in your stride
well i think um
ted rose from the who already put it the
right way that it is something we could
have done better and one of the most
critical point and best tools actually
we have is a vaccination worldwide so we
need to put more emphasis on vaccinating
in
other parts of the world where we have
only countries with two percent
vaccination rate and on the other hand
like people don't want want to get
vaccinated so we need to give more
explanation what a vaccine can do and
cannot so i think we are very much
focused on our home countries which is
on the one hand side critically
important for us but on the other hand
we can only end the pandemic if we are
really vaccinating everywhere in the
world
and you have been quoted as saying that
our grasp of the dynamic behind the
infection is not that great that
surprised me that comment for me in
layman's terms that seem to suggest that
that in the last two years we haven't
learnt an awful lot
well what i'm referring to is
particularly of what happens in germany
but also in other parts of the world
that we don't really understand the
incidences so how many people are every
day being infected what we are normally
are doing is to um just report the cases
that have been diagnosed but some
countries in the world like qatar or
england are actually doing
representative sentinel um
studies to understand how many people
are being infected if they are
vaccinated if they are not vaccinated
one from what social group they are from
so to better understand where we have
bigger outbreaks and what kind of
transmissions we have i think we can
learn more and i think we can be much
better in this and are we going to have
to accept that this this challenge to
our well-being is now here to stay
well this this is one important point to
realize that this virus is of course
becoming endemic so every winter we will
have larger waves at least in the
northern hemisphere
of
transmissions and infections of
covet 19 but every year we are becoming
more experienced with that and we will
also with vaccination and people who are
um recovered from covet 19 will not be
affected that much anymore so what i'm
expecting that we have a pretty
harsh winter again um
fall in winter where we have higher
rates of
infections but then with the spring and
summertime we will be getting more into
the time of an endemic and that probably
will happen worldwide okay pippa
stephens uh tell me a little bit about
the fears that people have in germany
about the winter that lies ahead the
harsh winter that lies ahead do you
share the concerns that many people are
expressing
well i think we've got a block of
unvaccinated people and it's difficult
to
see how that could
kind of be tackled and i think the
infection numbers are very concerning
and i think the hospitalizations as well
are also concerning and i can understand
why many people feel fear i mean the
german health ministry was saying that
triage you know wouldn't be needed but
even the fact that triage is being
mentioned um i think is is cause for
concern and surprised me as well to to
hear that word that doom laden word once
again yeah yeah and at the same time we
have merkel saying that um there won't
be another lockdown for vaccinated
people and i i find that a bit of a
discord actually
there's a lot of talk of staying on the
same uh the same point about the winter
there's a talk of
a calm before the storm
you know that sounds very very ominous
yeah i think
there are two things coming together
right now people have been in this
pandemic for quite a long time and they
really tried not to get infected and
they were really
really
kind of going with the restrictions and
at some point they get this sort of
pandemic fatigue and this is happening
on the one on the one side and then
we're seeing we have these immunity gaps
still so there's a block of people that
are not vaccinated there are people that
might have been vaccinated or infected
but are still very vulnerable to the
infection like old people and people
with immunosuppressant drugs any sorts
of things chronic diseases etc and this
is sort of coming together we still have
a lot of honorable people and uh people
are sort of fatigued
it's interesting that uh the the the
crisis has been compared or been
described as the most serious crisis or
one of the most serious crises since the
end of the second world war is it
relevant to ask who's you know what are
we getting wrong or is that the wrong
question
i think there's two things to say to
that the first thing is that it is a
relevant crisis and it would have been a
relevant crisis anyway no matter how we
acted i think that there was no perfect
reaction that would have prevented
everything
especially in the beginning when not
much was known about the virus and we
introduced a sort of lockdown in germany
on the other hand i guess we've had two
years we have a two years of experience
now with the virus and treating and and
kind of fighting the virus and i think
not enough lessons have been learned in
terms of how to prevent infections in
terms of reaching people with a
vaccination campaign etc so um that's
fair to say i guess should we have been
more vigilant
um in the first place yeah
um yeah i mean we've had
pandemics before we've had ebola we've
had sarsko v1 and afterwards the world
has said you know we we have to learn
from this we can't let this happen again
um and
and and it has and
um
yeah i i i and i'm concerned as well
that that even at this stage in the
pandemic i feel like governments just
aren't acting fast enough
i agree and it's interesting because i
mean the pandemics you mentioned were
pandemics that were kind of
easily suppressable more more easily
suppressible than star skull v2 is
basically and if you look at the german
reaction at the very beginning of the of
the epidemic in early 2020 suppression
went okay when we had this outbreak in
the car part factory basically but once
it spread was widespread i think we
noticed that there was not enough
expertise on on this pandemic that's
kind of really not an outbreak that you
can easily suppress
okay before we continue let's have a
look at the latest from two european
countries first denmark where most
people agree that things are getting
back to normal germany meanwhile risks
running out of momentum in its effort to
tackle the pandemic
denmark mid-september 50 000 people
gather for a concert in copenhagen the
mood is exhilarating
masks and social distancing everything
of the past
wow so many people it's incredible
the danes love their freedom and they
understand that with vaccination you can
get that freedom back
83 of danes above the age of 12 are
fully vaccinated life has mostly
returned to normal though currently
infection rates are rising sharply again
with a seven-day incidence of 207.
in germany the health minister plans to
end corona restrictions in november
maintaining that life will be back to
normal by spring
the parties likely to form the new
government coalition agree
meanwhile a fourth wave is building up
infection numbers are rising
vaccinations are stagnating at 64
and intensive care units are filling up
with the unvaccinated and cases of
vaccine breakthrough
how risky is a return to normal
the people of denmark jacob clearly
believe that uh they have more or less
returned to normal uh is that
complacency or is that do you do you uh
do you understand that position
i think denmark is in a different
position because they have higher
vaccination rates and they have a very
have done a very good job vaccinating
the high-risk groups that means
especially old people they have
vaccination rates of well be beyond like
95 percent in the older population parts
and that gives them kind of it puts them
in a better position than germany is
right now i think that's that's fair to
say at first and then denmark was very
transparent from the beginning on about
the strategy and i think that kind of
built a lot of trust with it with the
people and the whole strategy of really
getting people vaccinated getting
them on board work quite well um and i'm
not sure i mean looking at the winter i
guess nobody really knows where how
things will develop but i guess if you
do communication very openly very
transparently and you say we might turn
around at some point if it gets too dire
then that's fair and but it's just
something you have to be transparent
about and i guess nobody really knows
how the wind is going to be in denmark
communication is so very important
course yeah hendrick strike in in in
bonn when you see those images from
denmark and when you compare them to
other places uh in the world around
europe uh it's a very broad uh panorama
that we have we have some nations that
seem to be doing well others where
conditions are awful how do you explain
that
disparity between
different countries
first of all i fully agree what what was
just said by jacob um but um i i think
it's an important debate to have um when
um the
measures basically end and it is i find
it a wrong debate to have in the winter
time that we just know we will have high
rates of
infections but at the same time i think
we are currently in the transition
period from pandemic to endemic and
we will have to define an end to certain
measures hygiene concepts etc that being
said i think it's a wrong
discussion to have in the winter time
because we just know we will have high
numbers on infections and what we can
see in great britain or in denmark they
also despite the high rates of
vaccination they also have rising
numbers of infections so discussing this
now maybe for the spring springtime
where we know we will have a reduction
in numbers of infection at least in the
northern hemisphere i think it's a it's
a good start
and just going back to some of the
figures we heard we heard in that report
that 65 just over 65 percent
of the population in germany are fully
vaccinated that figure compares with 83
percent for the danes uh 80 percent in
spain
71 in italy and so on why is jab refusal
so high in germany
well first of all the skepticism against
vaccination in germany is like also
historically a little bit higher
compared to other countries
then
for other parts you can only speculate
there had been one study from denmark
that shows that there is just more trust
in the government in denmark
associated to
a higher vaccination rate and
in germany apparently we do not have
this really high number of trust in the
government in the measures against the
covet-19 pandemic and the third point um
italy and spain who have really high
rates of vaccination they had a lot of
deaths so they had suffered really
suffered through the covet-19 pandemic
and that might also bring people more uh
to actually get vaccinated okay but
again that's all at the end uh
speculation yeah and is it time to start
talking about mandatory vaccination you
nod yeah well i think it's a really i
think it's a really interesting question
actually um i
i know of a study in sweden where people
who were kind of um not completely
anti-vaccination but thought it was a
bit of a faff they were offered monetary
incentives and it worked it worked
really well um but in terms of kind of
accessing that that block of people who
just really really don't want to get
vaccinated um in countries like germany
i
you know i can't see many other options
but i think it's very country specific
like if you look at countries in
sub-saharan africa um i think it could
actually have the
the opposite effect it could be
counter-intuitive you know um if if
people are concerned about malaria about
tuberculosis about poverty no one's
doing anything and then the government
comes in and says you have to have this
vaccination you know and
and i think any loss of trust in in
in those countries would could be very
damaging
hendrick mandatory vaccination is it not
a very divisive strategy it is a very
divisive strategy i think oh it was for
hendrick
oh no sorry sorry
um
but and i guess before doing that
we need to really get the people who
are kind of still
kind of convinceable in a way and i
guess
we had the example of spain for example
and spain and england what they did is
they really addressed people personally
saying you can get vaccinated now for
example so they sent letters they even
sent letters with appointments for a
vaccination appointment basically and
people had to kind of cancel that so it
was kind of an out option there and the
same in germany i guess
there are a lot of people you could
still
reach by by kind of a well-designed
campaign and i look that means also
speaking about parts of the population
that don't speak german so we have a lot
of a lot of basically surveys looking
into vaccine skepticism and none of them
is really done in other languages than
german so we don't know anything about
non-german speaking people in germany so
and we also know from other from other
surveys that there's a correlation
between basically migratory background
like migration background and vaccine
acceptance acceptiveness and exactly
acceptance sorry and we also know that
about
trust towards kind of the state and we
know that people who have low trust in
basically the state don't get vaccinated
that regularly and so we have to think
about who's the person who approaches
people basically uh in order to convince
them to get vaccinated and that should
not be the state in many in many cases
but kind of people from their
communities from the major religious
groups etc so i think we need really
need to tailor the vaccination campaign
before we go in with a kind of
compulsory vaccination
for the mandate and make it easy for
people as well like it's it's hard it's
really hard like to to know why you
should get back vaccinated should be a
workplace should it be a vaccination
center in the first place and that could
be that could be a hurdle too and um
yeah i think just making it easy for
people and saying yeah this is this is
your appointment
very important point so let's change
change track just a little bit because
while many in the west struggle to come
to terms with kovid they do so
and i use the term advisedly in
comparative luxury in the global south
after all it's often a straightforward
matter of life and death and that
assessment certainly applies
to many countries across africa
corona vaccination is the exception not
the rule in many african countries
in some regions rates are as low as one
to two percent due to a lack of
available doses as a result the virus is
spreading and people are dying on mass
in cemeteries like this one in zimbabwe
it's one funeral after the other
in south africa the picture is different
there are more than enough doses yet
only 25 of the population has been
vaccinated
this is mostly due to the long distances
to the vaccination centers as well as to
superstition
many here believe that praying protects
against covid and that western medicine
causes infertility
aid organizations are sending
vaccination teams to the locations where
people collect their welfare benefits
still over 40 of south africans refuse
to get vaccinated
is africa falling behind in the fight
against coronavirus
hendrick stake the question i suppose is
not is africa falling behind but is is
africa being allowed to fall behind by
the more prosperous north and west
well um
we cannot allow that because
we we know that
we can only end the pandemic if you're
vaccinating worldwide in particular also
having a view on potential
mutations that can develop variants that
can be developed from
saskof2 that we cannot predict and so
how higher the viral load is worldwide
and so how more people are actually
infected with this virus as
more likely it is that we are having um
mutations or escape mutations that will
happen where vaccines do not work that
well anymore so it would harm us at the
end if we are not really vaccinating
everywhere in the world
pippa what do you say about that about
the the this very important point of
vaccine justice and the and that and
everybody in the world having access to
vaccination
yeah i mean i think the booster kind of
campaign has been the
the latest in what has been a very
unequal rollout and distribution and i
mean but that goes back sort of before
the pandemic and
um
the one one glimmer of hope i did have
is that biotech have announced they're
setting up a manufacturing plant um in
in africa to try and um yeah boost
manufacturing capabilities um but it's i
mean the optics that the optics are
terrible you know we had freedom day in
july in the uk and kind of parties like
in denmark and um but then you have
frontline workers who can't be you can't
be vaccinated it's yeah
jacob what do you think is the west is
is
is europe is the is the rich north and
the rich west doing enough to help to
help africa
in concrete terms i mean we talk about
it we ring our hands
we talk about a lot and a lot of people
say there need to be global solidarity
and then we've seen the west basically
buying up all the stocks of vaccines in
the last year
but i think we're about that might be
about to change i mean we're looking at
production capacity escalating we're
looking at
like
a smaller demand in the global north of
vaccines so i guess there will be a lot
of vaccines available especially
produced in india and in the upcoming
month and then it's a question also of
logistics reaching the people and
skepticism is a is a topic i think in in
a little film it was mentioned that the
the fear of of infertility after
vaccination that's not new we know about
that there were been like vaccination
campaigns with other vaccines in nigeria
for example where the topic came up and
we also know how to tackle that there is
kind of anthropological work on that and
i think we really need to do that we
really need to get on the ground we need
to get the logistics right for for
basically the upcoming months when a lot
of vaccines will be available so that's
looking to the future basically looking
to the future hendrick straight how
realistic does that does that
appear to you we
we need to get vaccines into the arms of
40 of people in all countries by the end
of this year says the wealth world
health organization it doesn't sound
likely that they're going to achieve
that in that time
no i agree it doesn't sound likely and
one one important point is that many um
individuals in the south are really
skeptic skeptic uh to get vaccinated
this is partially due because some pop
stars have said they can and a
vaccination can make you
infertile so you can't have any babies
anymore so um i i think one really
important point against
besides actually getting the vaccine
there is to have campaigns to
inform individuals about the benefit of
vaccination and take the fear of
potentially becoming infertile
and uh pepper steven's just one one
question about germany which is i think
is quite important everybody knows that
germany has got a
an old government going out in a new
government coming in how much is that
effect affecting the debate about how to
tackle the covid crisis in germany i
mean i i think it's it's sort of
stalling it and um it's difficult to
take decisive action if you're in flux
um but then i mean i you know i come
from the uk and it's also the federal
system is also
can can also be difficult to get
decisions through fast and we've seen
that since the pandemic started so for
me it's kind of it is um
yeah it's it's it's obviously affecting
how quickly we get um germany can act
but it's it's also yeah in in my mind
having one government it's kind of it's
also slow generally i think mm-hmm
yeah i'm sure can
we talked about the uh the the wealthy
countries struggling to help uh poorer
countries uh what impact do you think
the german government and the
developments there are having on that
in terms of the poorer countries yeah
i mean germany has been very outspoken
for like a global
equitable access to vaccines but um they
did not i mean but they also on the
other hand bought a lot of vaccines via
the eu for their own citizens first
but i guess germany will continue and
also the new government to push
basically for equitable access they are
very close ties between the old
government and and the who for example
and
so germany has always been very
outspoken about
that
for multilateral um global health system
that needs to be strengthened and that
also includes equitable access to
vaccines
everybody agrees that we were very
poorly prepared for the for the pandemic
two years ago are we just as poorly
prepared now
no but we're not so well prepared for
the winter i guess i mean we're having
rapid tests on the hand that that should
be used frequently in
all sorts of contexts also for like
vaccinated people who have still have
the risk of risk of transmitting and
getting the virus and transmitting it um
we have vaccines we have uh the first
therapeutics com coming onto the market
so i think we're way better prepared but
we're not
as as prepared as we could have been and
rick strait do you agree with that
assessment are we better prepared now
well i understood the question a little
bit differently and i thought the
question would um gear towards whether
we are better prepared for a future
pandemic
that might happen with a different virus
and i think if you it can go both ways
yeah
and and if if you're taking only this
aspect i agree that we are better
prepared than two years ago for for the
ongoing pandemic but for a future
pandemic we have not really
made big changes in particular in giving
who more rights to actually get go into
countries and
assess potential outbreaks with all
criticism that you might have at the who
it is actually that is something that we
need to foster and and to rebuild and
reshape in a way that we have a better
like emergency response team that can uh
yeah
uh future pandemics and actually contain
them at the beginning
pepper stevens the question we had at
the top of the show is there no end in
sight
well
i think
there will i think the pandemic the
global pandemic will end but my hope is
is that um we
grow to accept some measures like hand
washing and mask wearing on public
transport and that will help in you know
the week of the yearly flu crisis but
also in future pandemics which science
scientists say will be
sooner than we might think or hope okay
thank you very much for those closing
remarks we'll be talking about the
threat of cove with the ongoing threat
thanks very much for joining us bye bye
and trust
[Music]
you